today on the matt wall show as a
concerned community member i personally
attended a nashville school board
meeting yesterday to voice my opinion on
the district's universal mask mandate
many others were there on both sides of
the issue it was an illuminating
experience and i'll tell you about it
play some of the footage today also
andrew cuomo is resigning conservatives
are celebrating but the left is
celebrating two which tells me that
maybe this isn't the big win that we
think it is i'll explain and dr fauci
has some thoughts on freedom he's not a
fan of it apparently no surprise there
plus in our daily cancellation we ask
the question are master bedrooms racist
the answer might surprise you but
probably not all of that and more today
on the matt walsh show
you know if you've been listening to
this show for a while you've probably
heard me talk about my helix mattress uh
which is
and i don't just say this because i'm
paid to say i am paid to say but it also
happens to be true that it's the most
comfortable mattress i've ever slept on
um but they they have a new company that
they just launched called all form and
they're making premium customizable
sofas and chairs that are shipped right
to your door so what makes it all form
sofa really cool for starters it's the
easiest way you can customize the sofa
using premium materials at a fraction of
the cost of traditional stores you can
pick your fabric the sofa color the
color of the leg sofa size the shape to
make sure that it's perfect for you and
your home i don't know if you know this
but generally if you to get this kind of
sofa normally it's very very expensive
but with all form the other great thing
is you got you get you get to customize
you get a very comfortable uh very
stylish sofa and it's going to cost a
fraction of where it would almost
anywhere else
and you order it all all online it's
very easy they ship it right to your
door
and i cannot recommend it enough the
sofas are just as comfortable as the
mattress and that's the highest
recommendation i could possibly give so
and all form is offering 20 off all
orders for our listeners at
allform.comwalsh
so go there now again it's all form dot
com slash walsh
just last week our school board uh here
in nashville decided to instate a
universal mask mandate for all students
and all staff and anyone else who sets
foot inside the building on monday the
board outlined the punishments that will
be meted out to any child who dares to
show his bare face on school grounds
actually there are many other offenses a
student might commit beyond the indecent
exposure of his nose and mouth as the
tennessean reports the offenses include
quote refusing to wear a mask or
maintain social distancing
leaving a designated area or
intentionally exchanging bodily fluids
such as coughing or sneezing are
considered violations of the district's
protocols
coughing and sneezing now count as
misconduct
i'm sorry not coughing and seizing only
intentional coughing and sneezing
intentional coughing and sneezing in the
first degree with malice a forethought
that's what we're really worried about
you know
how do you distinguish between
intentional coughing and sneezing and
accidental coughing and sneezing
these details are not provided which
means that it'll be up to the schools to
decide whether any particular incident
of coughing qualifies as an infraction
or not
and if it is an offense the offender
better not make a habit of it because
the consequences can be quite dire more
from the tennessean it says
students who violate the district's
protocols could face discipline
including a student teacher conference
for the first offense let's stop there
for a second
uh i i'm trying to imagine a
student-teacher conference
where the where the where the
you know sitting down talking about a
cough
how long is that conversation going to
be
and then second offense is a
parent-teacher conference
so now the parents are going to sit down
and you have to the student there and
everyone's sitting down very solemnly
and the teacher says i need to talk to
you because your son
um coughed
in class
and we're pretty sure it was on purpose
but if this continues
um if there is a third offense
then suspension or expulsion may be next
as outlined by the district's student
handbook upon further incidents
now um
will we reach a point where a serial
coffer might actually be expelled yes we
can count on it
because a certain madness has gripped
hold of a large portion of the country
and there is no ceiling to this
craziness or perhaps i should say
there's no basement no floor we're going
to keep plunging because fearful people
are capable of just about anything
i witnessed this myself last night as i
attended the metro nashville school
board meeting to lend my support to the
sane parents who don't want to muzzle
their kids for eight hours a day
and also to make my own voice heard now
i should acknowledge at the outset that
yes
i homeschool my kids they aren't setting
foot inside a public school especially
not after what i witnessed last night
but
my money attends public schools in this
town i pay for them and so the school's
policies are very much my business also
i care about the mistreatment of
children even if they are not my own
imagine that
that's why i talk about issues like
abortion and the trans indoctrination of
kids and so on my kids aren't going to
be subjected to any of that either and
yet i still speak because these kids who
are subjected to it can't speak for
themselves
and need all the advocates they can get
now i've nonetheless been criticized for
daring to speak at the school board when
my kids don't attend but i've got news
for you this wasn't the last time
i kind of enjoyed it so they're going to
be hearing from me again and i can tell
you that and next time maybe i'll bring
three or four hundred friends along with
me
the public school system is a government
institution and i am a taxpayer which
means i get to make my voice heard and i
will repeatedly and loudly
and i certainly won't put my kids in the
middle of this lunacy just so that i can
have the right to do so
also note something else many of the
loudest voices in the country calling
for kids to be masked in public school
certainly do not send their kids to
public school many of them don't even
have kids
many of the loudest voices in the
country calling for masks in general
don't wear them themselves as we've seen
if they can get involved and have a say
so can i and so can you
now with that out of the way
back to the school board meeting
yesterday was in fact a big day for
school boards in the greater nashville
area south of here in williamson county
there was a
huge turnout of largely anti-mass
mandate people um many of them rallying
outside in addition to the hundreds of
people inside many spoke out against the
mandates there including clay travis he
was there based on what i saw on social
media and the news reports it seems that
it was a pretty inspiring turnout as
sanity outweighed insanity in williamson
county that is sanity outweighed
insanity
among the people
just not on the school board itself
unfortunately which still voted seven to
three to mandate the masks anyway
but that shouldn't be the end of the
discussion the pressure should stay on
these people for as long as the masks
are on the kids
now at our meeting the scene was a
little bit different
the board had already instated the mask
mandate before the public meeting
yesterday
met last week and then stated it and
then they had the meeting
um a sizable group of people showed up
to represent the pro freedom pro sanity
side but
this is downtown nashville which means
we had a large group of pro mask mandate
parents and teachers um who who were
there in attendance uh and there were
other markers to other signifiers
showing what we were up against
like for example the rainbow flags
decorating the boardroom and even
adorning the uniforms of the security
guards don't worry though they did have
the latest and most inclusive and also
ugliest rainbow flag
prominently displaying their special
support for the trans community
now the rainbow flag is of course a
leftist religious icon and has no place
in any school building or government
building of any kind separation of
church and state isn't that what we're
always told
but that's a problem we'll have to
tackle another day
and we will by the way
the public comments began with a whole
series of pro-mask mandate parents
many of these people were i can tell you
hysterical
completely hysterical
listening to these parents defending the
masked man many of them tearfully
thanking the school board for imposing
it
thank you for saving my kids with tears
in their eyes i'm not exaggerating
and watching this what jumped out at me
of course was the was was the fear
i mean they were sometimes literally
trembling in terror
deathly afraid that their children would
die from a virus that has killed
.008 percent
of the 42 million children it has
infected a mortality rate so low
that it simply is not rational to worry
about it
i tried to make that point when it was
my time to speak uh we'll play some of
that for you now
and by the way the city has not posted
the video of the meeting yet so we had
we had to make do with the cell phone
video my producer sean took the audio
isn't the best but bear with us um and
uh here it is
you and the school board have decided
that our kids should go to school all
day every day wearing muzzles like rabid
dogs i have listened to your arguments
and i've noticed that they're missing a
few things
namely evidence data science common
sense and basic human thesis
you presented no facts at all so let me
do that now here they are covent poses
almost no risk to our kids at all 4.2
million children have tested positive
for coping a total of
0.008 percent of them have done what
about the flu the cdc estimates that 480
kids died from the flu in the 2018-2019
season that's more than a diet from
cobit in a year and a half now did
anyone on this board suggest at any
point that year that kids wear masks did
anyone in this room suggest that at any
point anyone wear masks for flu which
again is more dangerous to kids than
covet that's a fact
[Applause]
do you know what it's called when you
force your children to wear masks for
fear of a virus that poses almost no
threat to them it's called child abuse
you want to look up a disease look up
munchausen byproxy because that's what
this is if you think i'm exaggerating
then how would you respond to a parent
who forced his kid to wear a football
helmet every day all day for fear of
falling coconuts and meteors your kid is
almost as likely to die of coat as he is
from a rock from the sky and yet if you
saw that you would say to that parent
that he is abusive but he is forcing his
kid to participate in this utterly
insane charade in order to satisfy his
delusional psychotic hypochondria now do
any of you know what sort of
psychological damage we do to children
by forcing them to cover their faces
teaching them that the air is toxic that
everyone around them is sick
deprive them of the ability to see each
other's faces do you know what kind of
damage that that does have you thought
about it
have you wondered about the health
effects of forcing kids to breathe
through sweat and spit and dirt soaked
rags every single day are you sure that
there are no health risks
do you know what the effect is on
children developmentally
if they're not able to read each other's
facial cues what about learning to read
and they can't see the teacher
enunciating the words
what does it do to a child's developing
immune system if you have to wear a mask
all day every day you're satisfied to
place this burden on children anyway and
why it's not to keep them safe they are
safe
right it's not to keep the adults safe
they can all get vaccinated if they want
no you do it to make yourselves feel
better and to protect yourselves
politically the child's
[Applause]
you know that guy raises some good
points
and uh pretty good looking guy too if i
have to if i do say so myself hit it
right there at the buzzer uh and that
was the the main thing i was uh the most
proud of they they give you three
minutes and they're pretty strict about
it so right at the buzzer
that's how you do it ladies and
gentlemen now um the point about the flu
has been made many times but we should
keep making it uh and i wasn't the only
person by the way in in the crowd there
to uh to bring up this issue of the flu
um because perhaps more than any other
point it reveals how completely
irrational our approach to covet has
been it's not that there was
less masking during flu seasons in the
past or even that people called for
basking but never succeeded in getting
the policies put in place until covet
you know no that's not what happened
nobody ever considered it it was not an
option on the table
nobody ever brought it up the people who
are now saying you're gonna kill my
child if you don't wear a mask
none of them
not one ever said anything during flu
season
and that's because although the flu is a
greater danger to kids
there was never any campaign to make us
afraid of it
we were all concerned about the flu
cautious about it to a certain extent
um we obviously didn't want to
get the flu or we didn't want it we
certainly didn't want our kids to get it
when i got a a terrible case of the flu
about a year and a half ago which now on
second thought i think was probably
covered but at the time we thought it
was was the flu
and um
and we had a newborn in the house
and it was you know and i was very very
sick for about three or four days
and i quarantined myself
in a room and basically didn't leave it
because i especially didn't want the
baby to get the flu because that could
be
really fatal
um the point is i didn't need anyone to
tell me that i didn't need i didn't i
didn't need to look at any guidance
guidance from the cdc
i didn't need a year and a half of
lecturing i just knew to do that because
i'm a rational person and i don't want
my kids to get sick
but even though we were concerned about
the flu we don't want our kids to get it
we maintained a proper perspective about
it and we continued living our lives
many people as i witnessed myself
firsthand last night have lost their
ability to do that
with covet
completely lost it
i mean lost it in like every sense of
the word
one i'm telling you one parent after
another losing it
barely able to speak
because they're so afraid
overwhelmed by their own fear
fears depend that fear is the pandemic
now
it is the virus
and notice something
it's the average citizen
it's the parent of the school child who
trembles in fear who literally cries to
the school board that she's afraid her
child will die the people putting these
policies in place the powers that be
they're not trembling
that's because they're not afraid
they know better
but they want you to be afraid because
your fear is the greatest gift to them
your fear makes you easy to control to
manipulate to persuade of anything
a fearful populist is a subjugated
populous fearful people become willful
slaves
roosevelt might have been onto something
after all
it sounds like cliche now but it's true
there's nothing to fear but fear itself
and that has never been more true than
it is today
now let's get to our five headlines
say folks have you heard that the great
courses plus is changing their name well
they are uh their new name is one dream
one dream is everything we know and
loved about the great courses plus and
so much more one dream provides
fantastic video and audio learning
experiences tons of great content to
enrich our lives with mind-blowing
moments because
listen learning and educating ourselves
it actually is learning is fun kids
education is fun it's not always fun at
school is the problem
um but uh even after you leave school
after you graduate how old you are you
got to keep learning and i think it's a
lot more fun when you do it on your own
of your own accord and that's what one
dream is all about we can still stream
all of our favorites from the great
courses including videos created in
partnership with national geographic
smithsonian history the culinary
institute of america and many more plus
entirely new and exciting programs as
well like one dream originals and
collections from kino lorber magellan tv
craftsy and many others uh plus
exclusive documentaries like the
award-winning winning film breaking
their silence all for no extra cost so
you got to sign up for this now through
my special url where you can get this
offer it's a free
14-day trial of unlimited access go to
onedream.com walsh that's
w-o-n-d-r-i-u-m.com
walsh onedrive.com walsh
all right we'll start with this here's
someone who is not afraid um chet hanks
founder of
white boy summer
um i think has has risen to the status
now of one of our nation's preeminent
public health experts in fact i would
and i don't even say this to be funny
if i was elected president
i would appoint chet hanks director of
the cdc
you know you could appoint
um
a a moldy tomato to be head of the cdc
and it would be better than what we have
now so it's not really saying much to
say that he would be better but he would
be i mean his his attitude to the virus
is far healthier
than what we hear from our so-called
public health experts and uh he's been
doing a lot of speaking out and i think
in part it's it's sort of to defend
white boy summer because how can we have
whiteboard summer if we're all wearing
masks and we're too afraid to go outside
uh so here's the latest from chet eggs
let's all just watch and uh bask in the
wisdom here
i'm so sick of this man dude flipping
barnes and noble
buying books
check out my mask looks like a little
millimeter past my nostrils oh sure you
got to have your mouth oh yeah my butt
not bad
slips down again sir your mask oh okay
my bad
i'm like i go i go you're really on it
huh he goes uh yeah we are
okay
he's like
did you get the vaccine i'm like yeah
yeah for sure i got the vaccine psych
if it ain't broke don't fix it i've
never had
kobe a man is uh
the man has a point he actually does
i i again i i don't even i don't say it
ironically to be funny he's got a he has
a healthier attitude about this than
half of the country more than half of
the country
and this whole bit
he's right to be annoyed by uh
especially it's not enough to wear the
damn mask
you know
um you you you also
it needs to be you got to keep it above
your your nose
well who cares why does that matter to
you
okay i i you know you could say well if
you have it if you have it below your
nose then you could still get sick well
what do you care about that
are do you really think let me ask you
something
do you really think
if someone has a mask on covering their
mouth
um
and they walk by you
or they're in line next to you at barnes
noble breathing through their nostrils
do you think
and this is someone who is
asymptomatic you know has has no known
symptoms of of cove it is not sick with
code as far as i know
uh
a healthy person
you think just from them standing near
you for a couple of seconds breathing
out of their nostrils they're gonna get
you sick when you have a mask on and are
vaccinated
what are the chances of that i don't
know i i don't know if anyone's done a
study on that
what do you think the chances are if you
are a va
you're someone and i'm assuming you're a
vaccinated person with a mask on if
you're that if you're if you're the kind
of person who would correct someone for
their for proper mask usage then i i
think we can guarantee you've got a mask
on in your um
and you're vaccinated so you're a
vaccinated person with a mask on
standing a few feet away for for a few
seconds
from someone who's also has a mask on
but they're breathing out the mouth you
you think they're just their
normal nostril fumes are going to get
you sick again what do you think the
chances are
what do you think they're 50 not even
close you think they're one percent i'm
i'm pretty much can
i can guess that they're far left far
less than one percent
far far far less
this is how irrational people have
become
which is why i could tell you this for
me when it comes to the mask thing now
i'm not doing it at all okay i'm not
playing the game at all
you walk into a place to tell you to
wear the mask i'm not going to wear it
if that means i can't go into place then
i won't go
i'm not doing it period
at the school board meeting yesterday uh
aft fortunately this happened after most
of us after i had already had a chance
to speak and most people had already had
a chance to speak and towards the end of
of public comments
they decided to mobilize security and
they said oh all you in here need to be
wearing masks or if you're not wearing
masks you have to leave so you know i
left and a lot of us did
because i'm not i'm just not going to do
it i'm not going to play that game
anymore
um
and that seems to be where where chet
hanks is right now which is good okay
moving from uh from covet and masking to
uh for just a few minutes to go to
andrew cuomo
who is stepping down from the
governorship
and uh and and i think
a pretty surprising development i didn't
expect that he would actually step down
um
although in hindsight
it it makes sense because the entire
political machine had turned turned
against him
and i think
you know for any democrat when they're
in that position
they're not going to know what to do
because it is so unprecedented
right they don't have a play in the
playbook for that
all of the all of the plays that
democrat politicians have in the book
all come with the assumption
that they're going to have the media on
their side
and all of the cultural institutions on
their side
they don't really have a play for when
that goes away because it almost never
does
you know it's like if you haven't if you
have a an offense in football that's
predicated on having a really good
offensive line and that's what the media
is for democrats they're playing
offensive line they're playing they're
they're kind of blocking
uh criticism and scrutiny and everything
else
well when your offense is predicated
that way and then your whole offensive
line goes down with injuries now you're
in trouble because you you weren't
factoring that possibility in really
and that's what happened andrew cuomo
was kind of out on an island um after he
uh lost all of his lead blockers and he
decided to step down here he is uh look
at the clip of him announcing
that he is i think we have a clip yes we
do here is announcing that he's stepping
down but he doesn't apologize or
anything and he does make himself the
victim but uh here that is
in many ways
i see the world through the eyes of my
daughters cara moriah and michaela
they are 26 and 26
twins and 23
and i have lived this experience with
and through them
i have sat on the couch
with them
hearing the ugly accusations for weeks
i have seen the look in their eyes
and the expression on their faces
and it hurt
i want my three jewels to know this
my greatest goal
is for them to have a better future than
the generations of women before them
it is still in many ways a man's world
it always has been
we have sexism that is culturalized and
institutionalized
my daughters
have more talent and natural natural
gifts than i ever had
i want to make sure that society allows
them to fly as high as their wings will
carry them
oh jeez andrew what are you doing
it's too late for this bud it's too late
for all this
but again this is the only play he has
in the book as a democrat he doesn't
know what else to do
he thinks he's going to save himself
somehow by
doing the girl power shtick now
the greatest people i know are women
men are scum the women are the greatest
they will fly as
high as their wings will carry them
women are angels flying through the sky
graceful beautiful specimens while we
men are down here in the muck
we disgusting men
it's it's it's no good it's too late
you lost
your team abandoned you this is it
android i don't know i don't know what
to tell you
um and speaking of his team the media
now has flipped to being very much
anti-cuomo
which is an interesting development in
general because he is a democrat also
it's it's hard to think of
immediately anyway any recent example
of
someone crashing and burning like this
going from such highs to such lows
politically in such a short amount of
time it was only a year ago
that the media was
almost literally singing his praises
as as as as choirs of angel singing
praises for the lord almighty i mean
that's that's almost what they were
doing he was he was winning emmys he was
he was on book tours
he was being hailed as the greatest most
popular politician in the country a year
ago
and now he's on his way out the door
let's go back and this is always fun to
do go back through memory lane
and uh just remember here's a a
compilation was put together by someone
not me
of uh the media
extolling
the virtues of andrew cuomo and all of
these clips are again not all that long
ago let's watch this
david we're standing by for governor
cuomo's press conference conference's
daily briefing how would you contrast
cuomo and president trump's handling of
the crisis
truth versus mendacity governor cuomo
out there day after day after day
everything trump isn't honest direct
brave real leadership of the kind the
president of the united states should
have provided governor cuomo
is clearly living in a totally different
reality
the actual one
than the president of the united states
governor cuomo has become a national
leader for a lot of people andrew cuomo
has become the leader of the democratic
party he is conveying incredible
strength you spoke to national guard
troops today in a stirring speech that
if i wasn't listening carefully i
thought you would sending soldiers off
to war this has been a remarkable show
of leadership by governor cuomo in
recent days he's providing hope
but not false hope governor cuomo i
think is is one of the heroes on the
front lines with all of this adulation
that you're getting for doing your job
are you thinking about running for
president andrew cuomo who has a daily
television show now uh and has become in
some ways the shadow uh president maybe
trump is just a little bit mad that
governor cuomo has become a kind of
acting president dealing with hardship
actually makes you stronger that's what
governor cuomo said earlier today that's
what i'm gonna go teach my kids right
now at home
he probably did it too
that goober he probably went home hey
kids i want to tell you something that
governor cuomo said today
he probably really did that
um
it it this was never going to last when
you think about it and it was even weird
at the time not because andrew cuomo was
actually a disaster as a governor and he
was directly responsible for thousands
of people dying especially elderly
people in nursing homes
that's not what made it weird to see the
media singing his praises because the
media sings the praises of horrible
democrat politicians all the time
um who have over seen you know horrific
disasters that have led to too many
people dying i mean that's that's a
normal thing
but what made it strange is that
andrew cuomo is you know an old white
guy
and
yeah they like biden but they've never
they've never talked about biden
in the same kind of terms that they you
were using for cuomo
and generally this kind of adulation
he's a hero he's this and that that is
reserved for non-white especially
non-male
people
so in some ways
it never could last this couldn't
continue
and now they've all turned on them why
did they turn on him that that's an
interesting question we can only
speculate
um
if if i had
if you'd asked me that question months
ago when this thing first broke then the
sexual harassment scandal at the time i
figured well they're doing this because
they want to cover and distract from
the nursing home scandal which they
realize is the greater scandal and most
importantly it's a scandal that
implicates more than just governor cuomo
because many democrat governors across
the country did the exact same thing
including in pennsylvania
and other states as well and so i
thought well maybe that's what this is
about
they need to take them down first they
need to get them out of the picture for
something to take the heat off of the
nursing home thing because they don't
want to talk about that and so they're
using sexual harassment but now you know
months later no one is really talking
about the nursing home scandal anymore
unfortunately he survived that
and yet they're still they're still
trying to take him down and they
succeeded and they're celebrating it and
it probably has a lot to do with 2024.
uh they don't want him to be the guy in
2024. he was flying a little bit too
close to the sun so they had to take him
out maybe that was the reason
but the fact is
that the media now is happy that he's
that he's gone
um
doesn't matter what they were saying a
year ago or six months ago they're happy
now the left is happy that he's gone
and that's why when i look at this i get
a little suspicious
and when i see conservatives celebrating
that governor cuomo has got his
comeuppance i think uh maybe maybe we
should slow down a little bit
i mean i'm perfectly happy to see miss
fortune befall governor cuomo like
anybody else cause he's a horrible
person was a horrible governor
but is this really
a win for the right
so if i got to be the guy as always
finding the dark cloud within the silver
lining then i would say
what actually happened here what
happened governor cuomo escapes any
consequence for the nursing home scandal
democrats avoid scrutiny for other
democratic governors who had the same
scandal
me too feminists get to claim a scalp
because they take him down for this
instead of the nursing home thing
while
a female
planned parenthood endorsed leftist
kathy hokul is the the lieutenant
governor she gets to take over
uh so is that actually
a victory
is that something we should be
celebrating
there's a very good chance the person
taking over will be a lot worse than
cuomo was
and will do the bidding of the left much
more than he did
and i i you know i was i was making this
point yesterday on twitter and i was
told by several people that oh well
kathy hokkiel
was she was endorsed by the nra back in
20 i think it was like 2010.
yes that means that she's a she's a
moderate democrat
come on
please stop
you think
you think
that the media would be happy as they
are
about an actual moderate demo do you do
you think a that a moderate that an
actual moderate democrat
could even be the lieutenant governor of
new york right now
yeah she was endorsed by the nra like 10
years ago around the same time
that that barack obama was defending
traditional marriage let's never forget
that he did that not all that long ago
his first term in office he was
pro-traditional marriage he was a
defender of traditional marriages first
term in office uh so around that time
kathy hulkiel was and i'm sure i'm
saying her name incorrectly doesn't
matter uh cathy hokkie was was being
endorsed by the nra and then
after after uh becoming lieutenant
governor she turned around and pushed
for gun control
and publicly accused anyone who is a gun
rights advocate of being a stooge of the
nra too afraid of the nra so that's what
the nra got for their trouble for
endorsing this woman she just turned
around and stabbed her right in the back
okay she took the the the uh
the shank out and shanked them right in
the in the back when they weren't
looking
that tells you a lot more about the nra
endorsing a new york democrat than it
does about the new york democrat herself
but she is endorsed by planned
parenthood and i can guarantee you right
now
that she is going to be more ideological
and more of a leftist
than andrew cuomo was
so word of warning
on one hand yeah it's it's nice to see
him go down for this but on the other
hand
um
it might be a loss for andrew cuomo and
that's what you're celebrating it is not
really a loss for the democrats they're
happy about this this works out for them
um and they're and they look they play
the game
i hate to say it but it's true that the
left and democrats they play the game at
a different level from most
conservatives and republicans
which is why many conservatives can't
see this as anything but a great thing
well he's a democrat and he something
bad happened to it's a good thing
democrats are playing at a different
level
and they're thinking five steps ahead
maybe we should start doing the same
okay dr fauci came out in favor of
vaccine mandates and his reasoning is uh
worth listening to
well it's not really but we're gonna
listen to it anyway uh not because it's
good but just actually for the opposite
reason here it is
do you think they should be mandated to
be vaccinated
yeah i'm gonna upset some people on this
but i think we should i mean we are in a
critical situation now we've had
615 000 plus
deaths and we are in a major surge now
as we're going into the fall into the
school season this is very serious
business you would wish that people
would see why it's so important to get
vaccinated but you're not going to get
mandates centrally from the federal
government but when you're talking about
local mandates mandates for schools for
teachers for universities for colleges
i'm sorry i i mean i know people must
like to have their individual freedom
and not be told to do something but i
think we're in such a serious situation
now that under certain circumstances
mandates should be done
yeah people like to have their freedom
yeah it's it's
it's it's cute you know you you people
you you like to have your freedom but
it's um
that's that's more of a of a privilege
that's more of a luxury that uh you know
we don't we don't have time for freedom
right now
this is this is
one of those things you know it's
under normal circumstances when everyone
is feeling quite safe and happy and um
and there isn't something like covet out
there that the media is generating panic
over
and i mean increasingly they're always
generating panic about something so we
don't really get these moments anymore
but in the past
um
almost everyone
would would say would declare
courageously and bravely that
they care more about freedom than safety
freedom is the most important thing i'll
take freedom over safety and they'd
paraphrase uh
the founding fathers about how how
we should never exchange freedom for
safety and so on and so forth
and probably probably even now i don't
know this would be an interesting thing
to poll actually but
certainly before this
if you had done some sort of poll
and asked americans of all ideological
stripes
what do you think what is more important
to you as an american freedom or safety
i would bet you prior to 18 months ago
uh you get 99 saying
of course freedom is the most important
thing
and
there there is such cognitive dissonance
that even now i bet you
you would get a
a clear majority saying freedom is the
most important
but then when something comes along
that actually jeopardizes your safety
potentially
even if only minimally
from a statistical standpoint
when that thing comes along
um that's when the rubber meets the road
and it's time to just to find out do you
actually value
freedom or not
and it turns out that most people don't
that's the unfortunate reality
most people freedom is the kind of thing
that most people don't value and by the
way
that's why most people in the world and
throughout history aren't really free
you know because to begin with
starting point
in order for people to be really free
they have to want to be that's that's
the first thing you have to you have to
value it and want it you have to value
your own liberty
if you don't then there's no hope
and what we discover is that most people
don't
and um
they certainly don't in modern america
they value their safety and they want to
be comfortable
and i think most people look at their
lives and they say well what is freedom
what do i need freedom for what does
that do for me who cares about that
what what do i want to do with my time
i want to
be be well-fed i want to be able to eat
anything that i can eat and um i want to
spend time inside watching netflix and
playing video games
and i want to scroll the internet and i
want to go on tick-tock and instagram
and that's that's all i want to do
that's what i want to do with my time
that's what i want to do with my life i
don't care about anything else
that's the attitude of most people in
this country and they say and rightly in
fact i don't need freedom for that
i can be totally
oppressed i could have almost no freedom
and and i'd still be happy i mean the
government could come and
literally put a padlock on the outside
of my front door and force me to stay
inside and you know i'd probably be okay
cause most of stuff i want to do is
inside anyway it's on this screen it's
on my phone it's on the tv
that's that's the attitude and we're
seeing now the consequences of it
all right let's move on now to reading
the comments this is from thor he says
seriously matt cut simone biles a break
how is she supposed to think rationally
about any moral issue when she has the
twisties
you bastard i wish i'd thought of that
joke that should have been my joke
you're banned from the show but nice job
um living woman ministries says matt i
came from foster then was later adopted
i was abused until i was 16.
still i'd rather have lived through all
of that than with my crack-headed mother
and her boyfriend while eating paint off
the walls because i was hungry which
gave me lead poisoning or watching him
almost kill her it is that easy foster
care reform yes more affordable adoption
agencies yes but abortion no
well that's a horrific story i'm sorry
when you lived through that and i'm glad
you did live though through that and
survive and uh it sounds like now you're
thriving and the thing is
i said this yesterday
being in the pro-life movement
and um going to you know events and and
protests and rallies and things
um
and meeting other pro-life people you
you come across these stories all the
time and and that doesn't make them any
less powerful they're so powerful every
time you hear them
but there are so many people very
invested
in the pro-life movement who themselves
were adopted they were in foster care
they had horrific childhoods
that unimaginable to most of us to me
and yet they're still saying
i'm glad i lived i'm glad that my mother
at least chose life
at least she did that much for me
um what does that tell you
and what does it tell you that that so
often many of the most vocal proponents
of the pro-abortion side
they didn't have childhoods like that
they grew up pretty comfortable
and yet they're now sitting back on
their comfortable perch and saying about
all these kids in these dire situations
that well they might as well be dead
what's what's the point of life
because for them go back to what we just
said we're talking about a second ago
for them they've always been comfortable
they've always lived in luxury they've
never suffered they've never had to make
any sacrifices
and they've come so accustomed to it
they can't imagine life without it and
and when they think of a less
comfortable life
much less a life that features real
incredible suffering like in the comment
we just read there for them it seems
like you might as well not have life
because for them the concept of life is
inextricably linked with comfort and
luxury because that's how what their
life has always been
they can't conceptualize how anyone
could suffer so greatly and yet still be
happy to live
um
cool papa j magic says immediate cringe
when white house and tick-tock
influencer are in the same sentence yes
or when they're in separate sentences
also is a time for cringing
um another comment says he mispronounced
penis as phineas i can't
no actually i pronounced it as penis
which is the proper and dignified way to
say the word
mr tubin sir your penis is on display
sir
have you no shame sir
that's how it's used in a sentence
um lexi says cyclists could be annoying
yes but i believe matt should address
the people who drive large tractors down
the road and refuse to pull to the side
when there are dozens of cars trailing
behind them many times the cars behind
can't see around them and it can be very
unsafe i've seen many near collisions
when a car tries to pass and nearly hits
a car coming the other way because they
can't see them i i see your point it is
certainly annoying
um having just moved from a rural area i
that's something i encountered all the
time
tractors
and
yeah it's annoying but i don't put that
in the same category at all as cyclists
because the person on the tractor if
they're just going for a joyride then
yeah i agree with you get the hell off
the road but most of them are not on a
joyride they're they're working and they
they need to get from point a to point b
and so they have to get on the road and
you know it's not like they're on the
road most of the time for 80 miles not
getting on the highway um they're on a
back country road and they got to get
from point a to point b in the process
of of working so they are using the road
for what it's meant to be used for and
this is not recreational what gets me
about
the cyclists is that most of them this
is recreation this is something they do
because it's fun
and now the rest of us have to be
inconvenienced because you're having a
good time
that i don't like
um victor says would matt read a comment
that is only here to help the algorithm
no sir i would not absolutely not
um
uh curos says after just reading after
just finding this channel and watching a
ton of videos i have to think that this
is the first thing i've ever disagreed
with you on as i'm highly pro-choice
well you've watched a ton of my videos
and you're just learning that i'm
pro-life
how is that does that not come through
in everything i say
that's like if someone said matt i've
been listening to you for a year i've
listened everything you've said and now
all of a sudden you tell me you're
against the trans agenda i had no idea
um
and
finally cj says love your show matt but
just because someone doesn't have kids
that doesn't automatically mean that
they have it easier they also don't get
child support checks and are far less
eligible for financial assistance than
single parents
i've known plenty of people who get so
much money just for being single parents
that they don't even need to earn an
income at all a single person may not
have dependents but they also have zero
support
uh zero support system well first of all
that's not true i mean single people
during during covet have been getting a
lot of money left and right so you're
not actually right about that of course
this is not a
this is a broad statement a general
statement but it doesn't apply there are
exceptions it doesn't apply in every
case a single person can have a special
particular unique circumstance that
makes their life a lot harder than
someone with with kids obviously if
you're suffering you know you could be
suffering some sort of physical
um
disability or something like that that
makes it harder to find a job and
everything else
but all all other things being equal
assuming we're talking about physically
healthy people
and you have one on one hand that has a
family to feed and another on the other
hand who is single has no dependence at
all
yeah especially when we're talking about
supporting yourself and
living and getting jobs and all that
as a single person you're gonna have it
a lot easier definitely
because no one else depends on you you
can do whatever you want
and i don't say that as as some sort of
pissing contest between us where i'm
saying i'm a parent and my life is so
much harder now what i'm saying to you
if you're in this category cj which
maybe i assume you are
this is a great thing take advantage of
it
okay it's also great to be a parent to
have to have a family
but while there are advantages
to being a single person especially
early on in life when you're younger and
you haven't yet got to that point in
your life where you're where you have a
family um
take advantage of that
it annoys me to no end it it distresses
me it causes me sorrow even
when i see younger people in their early
20s who are single they have no
dependents
and they sit around all day and they
don't have a job and they say i can't
find a job i don't know where to go
there are no jobs right even though
there's 10 million jobs available right
now literally uh i can't find a job i
can't do this i can't do that
what are you doing you
there's no you can do anything just get
up you can move you can find a job that
you want anywhere in the world and go to
it
not only do you have that ability but
it's an adventure that you can that you
can go on it's an experience
that you can let when you later when you
have kids you can tell them about it
you can do anything so go do it what are
you sitting around here for
there's no excuse for that
it doesn't matter if you find a job in
south dakota
or
in hawaii like anywhere
you could be totally mobile
and you also know that when you you can
take risks
i mean as
we should always be taking calculated
risks
even when you become when you have a
family but before you have a family
the calculation is different and you
could take greater risks
because the downside is is is not quite
as steep
so let's say you move somewhere for a
job opportunity it doesn't work out
and now you're out there and and
what's like worst case scenario
you end up losing your apartment you
have to sleep in your car for a few
weeks before you find someone else to
stay that's not good you don't want to
have to do that but i tell you something
you can do it as a single person as a
single young person physically healthy
many of us have done stuff like that
because we had to
it's a lot different when you have kids
now all of a sudden you can't be so
flippant about it
i just i wish you would take advantage
of it and go and and explore the world
and take big risks and and go and pursue
opportunities
and do it with like a a a gusto and an
ambition and even a certain recklessness
that you that you're not going to be
able to afford later in life now's your
time to do it so do it
that was my motivational speech for the
day
say folks have you heard that ben
shapiro has a new book out well he does
the authoritarian moment is what the
book is called and there could not be a
better time or more appropriate time for
it uh it's what we talked about today on
the show we talk about it every day
because this is what we're dealing with
in the culture is the leftist tyrants
taking over and uh removing our freedom
and our liberties if you want to know
all about that and also what we can do
about it you got to pick up the
authoritarian moment now available
amazon barnes noble or any other major
bookseller and
if there's any time to enter to win a
free trip to the daily wire studio to
meet canis owens and see her live show
it is now
if you sign up now as a daily wire
member with code vip you'll get 25 off
your new membership and be automatically
entered for a chance to win a trip for
two to the daily wire studios to see
candace
live and um
if you're lucky it's a show that i will
be starring on uh but even if i'm not
it's still worth seeing not quite as as
worth it as it would be otherwise but
still not only will you be meeting
candace you'll be getting an inside look
at her studio and front row seats to
watch her take down leftist live and in
action on her talk show candace so get a
great deal on a new daily wire
membership at dailywire.com subscribe
with code vip and 25 off so you can
automatically be entered for a chance to
win the vip experience now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
we began the show talking about fear and
that's how we'll end it with our daily
cancellation many people in fact fear
the daily cancellation knowing that if
they're canceled by me then well
nothing at all will happen to them but
still they tremble and tear or so i like
to tell myself in any case we know that
kovit is not the only existential threat
that we're meant to so deeply fear
uh it's not the only boogeyman hiding
around every corner or the only monster
on the prowl lurking waiting to descend
upon us and rip us limb from limb if we
dare to leave our homes there are a few
other beasts of this type including of
course racism
our cultural overlords have convinced us
many of us anyway that our country is
brimming with racism america is they
tell us a bubbling cauldron of white
supremacy
black
being accosted or peop assaulted and
murdered by white racists
the problem is that this is all entirely
mythological it doesn't reflect reality
or come close to it we're told that
there are white racists everywhere and
yet we can't find them almost anywhere
for the rational among us this leads us
to the logical conclusion that the
narrative is simply false
but the irrational unable to process the
possibility that a media narrative might
be untrue god forbid instead fill in the
blanks with their own imaginations it
becomes like a game of looking up at the
sky and discerning the shapes of the
clouds you know
you might look at a cloud and see
nothing but a white and gray blob but if
someone points to it and says hey that
looks kind of like a triceratops
then you look back at it and you say oh
okay yeah i can see that now i can see
the triceratops
you can imagine that you see it
this is how the irrational mob
approaches racism
because they've already been told that
it's there they start to see it too
even if they wouldn't have seen it
without that preconditioning without
that suggestion
a perfect example of this phenomenon is
the recent controversy over a fan at a
colorado rockies game who allegedly
yelled a racial slur
while miami marlins player louis brynson
who was black was up at bat a fan in the
stands sitting in the front can be heard
shouting something it was decided by the
social media mob that he shouted the
n-word and so they immediately mobilized
to track this guy down and bring him to
justice in the whole nine yards but of
course as it turns out
he didn't say the n-word at all here's
the clip that made its way to twitter
and uh started all that let's listen
okay
three yesterday here's the 1-0
[Music]
and again it's 2-0 and this is not to
pick on on ben today
three yesterday here's the 1-0
and again it's 2-0 and this is not to
pick on on
three yesterday here's the 1-0
and again it's 2-0 and this is not to
pick on
okay
it's a good thing that clip is only a
few seconds long because my limit is one
minute if i have to watch baseball for
any more than one minute i immediately
fall asleep but gr groggy as i was
while watching that
and before knowing what exactly the guy
was saying
it was already clear to me from the
context that he definitely wasn't
shouting the n-word least of all was he
shouting it at the at the player that
was at bat
first of all he's supposed to be
shouting it at the batter but he's
looking he's not looking at the batter
he's looking off to the side he's
clearly waving to someone to the side
who looks off to the side in the stands
while shouting at a player you ever seen
it let's look at you're standing right
there at the where the camera is that's
you and i'm looking over here hey hey
over here
clearly he's not talking to that guy
also
let's pretend this guy is the biggest
racist in the world he's not but let's
say he was
do you really think he would commit
suicide by shouting the n-word at the
top of his lungs on camera
in front of a in the front row of a
major league baseball game
and if he was committing such an act of
self-immolation why wasn't anyone in the
stands reacting nobody looks at the guy
there's no commotion in the stands at
all as there certainly would be if a
white guy was screaming the n-word at
the batter
this alone is enough to tell a rational
person that whatever the dude was saying
it wasn't that and yet the irrational
people convinced that racism is lurking
everywhere can fill in these blanks too
they figure well you know of course he'd
shout the n word that's what all old
white guys do the guy probably walks
around every day shouting it he probably
gets together with his buddies and
shouts it for fun his recreation
probably calls his friends up and says
hey you want to come over and shout the
n-word
are you sure we just did that yesterday
yeah i felt like doing it again okay
why wasn't anyone reacting well because
they're all racist too and uh they're
used to hearing the n-word shouted
because they also shot at themselves for
fun on a daily if not hourly basis
when you've been deluded into believe in
the media narrative this is the kind of
mental gymnastics you do with little
effort
so it doesn't much matter that the
colorado rockies investigated this
incident because this is the kind of
stuff we investigate now and concluded
with certainty that the fan in in
question was shouting at the team mascot
dinger
and that makes sense because when you
you can see him in the video
pointing and waving towards the mascot
turns out he was talking to the mascot
huh okay that's how you fit those
those uh two dots together that's how
you connect the dots there
that should put an end to the
controversy but um in a controversy it
never should have started in the first
place but it won't because
people will refuse to believe it or else
will say that even if the fan didn't say
the n-word then he probably has said it
before and so he deserves to be doxed
and destroyed anyway
but that
isn't even the most absurd case of fake
racism this week
for that we turn to the star tribune in
an article titled no more master
bedrooms minnesota real estate listings
aim for inclusivity
we are told quote browse through home
listings today and you'll find terms
like primary bedroom dual closet and
in-law suites instead of master bedroom
his and her closets and mother-in-law
seats suites it's part of a new real
estate terminology that's emerging
during a time of racial reckoning and
pleas for more inclusive language
quote there's a hidden discriminatory
piece that falls when you say master
bedroom said jackie berry a listing
agent for edna realty and an educator in
a racism and real estate continuing
education class for minnesota industry
professionals
i'm a person of color and every time the
term master bedroom was used i kept
saying to myself i don't like how it
sounds
now as i'm walking through a property
i'll just say it's the owners or primary
suite
in recent years several twin cities area
twin city area listing agents and real
estate companies have been phasing out
the word master because of its
association with slavery
but we're still going to use the word
owner
okay
attorney ben crump
who's the lawyer who repels down from a
helicopter and holds a press conference
within five minutes of any violent black
suspect getting shot by the cops he
tweeted this article out and he offered
his words of support for the move saying
quote
words matter
good to see minnesota phasing out the
use of master bedroom and real estate
listings many associated with slavery a
repetitive reminder of plantation life
together we can create more inclusive
aware communities
yes many associate master bedroom with
slavery
and many associate the words ben crump
with ambulance chasing race hustling
lying scumbag
the difference is
the latter association makes sense
as far as those who associate master
bedroom with slavery there's a word for
them
um wrong
they're just wrong the two things have
nothing to do with each other
master bedroom was first used in a sears
catalog about six decades after slavery
was abolished
i'm sure that slave owners did sleep in
bedrooms which perhaps is an argument
for abolishing all rooms if not all
houses
but the terminology has nothing to do
with it
indeed the word master appears all over
the english language
in many other contexts that are equally
innocuous
perhaps next we need to get we need to
find new words for
masterpiece mastermind post master
quarter master
not to mention jeffrey toobin's favorite
pastime all of these master words have
nothing to do with slavery or racism
less of course everything has something
to do with slavery and racism
maybe that ultimately is the answer here
i don't know
as all words phrases ideas things people
and concepts can in some way be tied
back to slavery and racism maybe we
should abolish them all
the world should become a place devoid
of life and light and substance an empty
abyss much like ben crump's brain
that that's the only way we can ever be
free of racism
is through the utter and complete
annihilation of all things how will we
accomplish this
i don't know
maybe we could find some way to
jettison the entire planet into a black
hole except of course we won't call it
that
either that
or we can choose sanity and truth
which means to begin with saying to ben
crumb and the frantic race obsessed
outrage mob
you are all canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day everyone godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producer is mathis glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
21.
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our new show morning wire on
today's episode new york governor andrew
cuomo resigns chicago police turned
their backs on the mayor and the u.s has
a record 10.1 million job openings join
us and get the facts first on the news
you need to know with our show
morningwire
[Music]